by the end of the 21st century humanity
is becoming desperate
decades of heat waves and droughts have
led to unusually poor harvests while the
warming oceans yield fewer fish each
year
in the tropical zones millions suffer
from famines and resource wars have made
millions more flee to the north
as things quickly get worse in an act of
desperation the world's governments
decide to enact an emergency plan
it's far from certain that a grim
scenario like this will play out but the
failure of world leaders to effectively
address climate change makes it far from
impossible
so in the near future it might become
necessary to try something radical to
slow down rapid climate change
geoengineering
interventions so massive in scale that
they might undo centuries of human
behavior or make everything much worse
what is geoengineering is it really an
option and what if it goes wrong
[Music]
geo engineering methods vary from
fantastic ones like constructing giant
light sails in space to seeding clouds
with salt or wilder ones like
fertilizing the oceans with iron to
speed up the growth of trillions of
algae cells
in this video we'll focus on an
intervention we could see during our
lifetimes stratospheric
injection
a clunky term that means spraying stuff
very high up in the atmosphere to keep
the sun away
keeping the sun away
co2 doesn't heat up the planet on its
own almost all of the energy on earth
comes from the sun in the form of
electromagnetic radiation
about 71 percent of this energy is
absorbed by the earth's surface and
atmosphere
this absorbed energy is emitted again as
infrared radiation and co2 is able to
trap this infrared radiation and keep it
in the atmosphere for a while
you can compare this effect with
snuggling under a blanket in the morning
even in a really cold room your body
emits infrared radiation and the air
between your body and the blanket traps
it and creates a warm and comfy feeling
so one way to cool down the planet would
be to prevent energy from getting
trapped under our planet blanket
which is already happening naturally
about 29 of the solar radiation hitting
earth is reflected back to space by
bright surfaces like ice deserts snow or
clouds
more reflection less energy less warming
we can look at nature for inspiration
specifically the 1991 mount pinatubo
eruption the second largest volcanic
eruption of the 20th century
aside from massive devastation and
almost 900 dead scientists noted its
strong impact on the global climate
the explosion ejected millions of tons
of particles and gas as high as the
stratosphere which hung around there for
a while
the stuff that's interesting for
geoengineering is sulfur dioxide a nasty
smelling and invisible gas
high in the atmosphere it produced a
haze of sulfuric acid droplets that
mixed with water and created giant veils
these veils reduced the sunlight
reaching earth's surface by roughly one
percent
global average temperatures dropped by
0.5 degrees celsius
it took three years until this cooling
effect had stopped
humans could imitate this process by
injecting sulfur particles directly into
the stratosphere according to some
scientists this might be surprisingly
easy to do and we don't even need a lot
of new technology for it
according to one study it also might be
pretty cheap compared with the costs of
rapid climate change
a small fleet of specialized aircraft
could ascend once a year and distribute
aerosols along the equator from where
they would be spread around the world
projections assume that injecting
between five and eight megatons of
material per year would reflect enough
sunlight to slow down or even stop
global warming giving us precious time
to transition away from fossil fuels
unfortunately there might be a few
unhappy side effects
there are a number of potential issues
with aerosol injections
rainfall patterns could change which
could negatively affect agriculture and
cause famine billions of people could be
affected in the worst case
also after the 1991 mount pinatubo
eruption the acid water veils not only
cooled down the surface they also heated
up the stratosphere as it turns out acid
is bad for the ozone layer and the ozone
hole over antarctica was the largest it
has ever been
injecting sulfur particles over decades
could have a similar effect
scientists have already suggested using
a combination of different minerals that
might have much less harmful effects on
the ozone layer but more research and
experiments need to be done to make sure
this could work
but even if we don't damage the ozone
layer there are other risks
politicians and industry might use the
cooling effect as an excuse to delay the
switch to a carbon neutral economy
even if geoengineering slows down global
warming humanity is still adding extra
co2 to the atmosphere more co2 in the
air means that the oceans absorb more
co2 which makes them more acidic
this is already beginning to be deadly
to huge ecosystems like coral reefs and
the longer this continues the more
severe the effects will be
but it gets worse
once we start pumping particles into the
atmosphere on a massive scale we might
be forced to do so for a long time or we
could risk a termination shock
what that means is that if humanity
continues to enrich the atmosphere with
co2 but at the same time prevents the
planet from heating up by blocking solar
radiation we're sitting on a time bomb
once we stop geoengineering the natural
cycle will take over again and earth
would heat up
but after a few decades of keeping the
planet artificially cold while still
releasing massive amounts of co2 it
would heat up much much quicker an
increase in temperature that would take
50 years today could happen in just 10
years
such a temperature shock in such a short
time would disrupt every major system on
earth so much that it would be
impossible to adapt in time
the worst case scenario could be
dramatic famines and the rapid
destruction of ecosystems
humanity might survive but the survivors
would inhabit an unfamiliar and hostile
world
the best case scenario is that once the
world has finally fully understood the
existential danger of rapid climate
change geoengineering can buy us a
crucial decade or two
time to transition our economies and
maybe even pull co2 out of the
atmosphere maybe with technologies that
we'll discuss in a future video
conclusion
geoengineering is a scary concept it's
not a solution to climate change and it
might even be a welcome excuse for the
fossil fuel industry to delay the end of
the fossil fuel age
over the last few decades geoengineering
has been so controversial that it
stopped many scientists from doing the
experiments necessary to understand it
better
but blankly opposing geoengineering is
short-sighted the sad truth is we are
already running a geo-engineering
experiment we're testing how fast the
world changes if we add about 40 billion
tons of co2 each year
this experiment is about to get really
exciting hopefully we'll never have to
use geoengineering but if we need to in
the future we better have done the
science
we better be prepared
or a panicking humanity might
accidentally press the self-destruct
button
[Music]
you probably won't have to do any of
that yourself but who knows better brush
up on your science knowledge just in
case and our friends at brilliant can
help you with that brilliant is a
problem-solving website and app that
makes science accessible in a practical
way more than 60 interactive courses
give you the tools to crack problems in
maths logic and engineering all by
yourself
instead of a classic lecture format
brilliant uses storytelling code writing
and hands-on problems to keep you
entertained and engaged
this way a small daily challenge can
build up to real long-term understanding
of science and achieving your stem goals
in a nutshell brilliant surprises you
and keeps you on your toes all while
sneaking some knowledge into your head
without you really noticing write up
already really
to get a fresh perspective on science go
to brilliant.org nutshell and sign up
for free
and there's an extra perk for kutzgazak
viewers the first 200 people to use the
link get 20 off their annual membership
which lets you view all the daily
problems in the archives and unlock
every course
brilliant helps you end your day a
little smarter still the best
preparation for the future we can think
of
[Music]
[Music]
you